Copper and Zinc is another thing that I'm starting to run more tests of Copper and Zinc
because there's some new data coming out that high copper levels can feed cancer.
So when I'll put a video together on this in detail, but we don't want high copper levels.
And there's some new data coming out that low zinc levels can be a problem
and can be responsible for giving relatively high copper levels.
So you want to do a test that measures both copper and Zinc and then look at the ratio of Zinc to Copper or Copper to Zinc.
Because that is imported with cancer.
So we are starting to run those blood tests if you want to do that.
Let me know it's a blood spot test that I sent out to you and you prick your figure and put the blood drops on this little card.
You let it dry and you spill it in and it's a really nice little test to measure your Zinc copper ratio.
In that test, we also do a urine test and we get iodine in that same test.
And some other things like lead and mercury and other metals that could be causing problems too.
But that's a nice thing to look at.
I was at a seminar this weekend.
That's where I did those one videos that you saw that I put up on Facebook.
And if you haven't watched those, I really recommend that you do.
But Zinc and Copper levels.
Also, somebody made a comment that I don't remember that they missed last Zoom call.
All the Zoom calls, any new videos that I create, any new information that I create, I'm putting it on your Facebook page first.
So all you miss a Zoom call, watch it.
Again, it'll be posted up on this Facebook page.
I love going to seminars because I get to rob shoulders with like-minded doctors.
And this one was important because there was a lot of cancer stuff at the seminar.
And one of my colleagues was talking about a patient that he had that had uncontrolled prostate cancer that had spread to the bone, had spread to the lung and spread to the liver.
And it was his PSA was just flying off the roof and it was not looking good for this young, this older man.
And he had done some research on Zinc and he decided to do an experiment because this guy was at the end of his role.
He was willing to try anything.
And he injected Zinc under MRI into this man's prostate, into the man's cancer on his ribs, and into the man's cancer on his lungs.
He didn't, I don't think he had it as liver.
And in all the areas, the cancer shrug literally within a couple weeks.
So that was like super prophesied.
The problem is, is that's not necessarily, quote unquote, legal to do that.
So find somebody to do that.
I mean, because if you're going to try to get it into the prostate, you would have to do it under MRI.
So this guy was out of country, out of the country that did this.
So he could get by with it, but you couldn't find anybody in the States to do that.
Now, if you had breast cancer, you could get a needle injected into your breasts. That would be pretty easy.
But to get it into, you know, a deep organ, you'd have to do it under MRI or ultrasound. That's not quite as easy.
But that got me thinking, okay, so you could use a driver like DMSO with ZIG.
So using a driver like DMSO with ZIG, that's a possibility.
So if we look at a person's, here's a slide about eye and eye deficiency at breast cancer.
But if we looked at a person's ZIG in copper and their ZIG copper ratio,
and that was not where we wanted it to be, this is an example of a normal test there,
I thought, well, what the heck, I would have created my own thing.
Yeah, I did.
So I created a ZIG DMSO topical solution.
And this is, you can't see it, but it's a spray bottle that you could spray it on an area.
Now, if I had prostate cancer, is it going to go as deep at the prostate? No, it's not.
But if I have kids who are in a bone, a rib, a lug, would it go that deep?
Yeah, it could. It certainly can't hurt you.
So DMSO is widely used as an anti-inflammatory.
So that's, there is a wrong with using DMSO. It's ZIG.
There is really no toxic load of ZIG.
Though, I don't have the exact milligrams, but probably per spray.
It's only about five milligrams of ZIG, maybe at the highest in which you'd absorb is maybe wood.
So this is another solution that I'm going to introduce, definitely to my breast cancer patients,
that I want them to spray right out their breast, right over the tumor, and just rub it in.
It just feels like a water.
The only negatives with DMSO is it smells kind of garlicky.
And you could get a oystery, garlicky taste in your mouth afterwards, because it literally can absorb in a minute.
And you could get that taste in your mouth.
I, of course, tried it up myself and did it on a bunch of areas of my body, and I didn't get that taste at all.
But so I think it depends on the quantity that you use.
But this is another solution to increase ZIG stores.
The problem with ZIG is you could take it orally too, and I recommend that.
But I recommend a whole food ZIG.
That's the ZIG liver key late by standard process.
I don't have a picture of that, but that's the, that's a whole food source of ZIG.
But do you, when you absorb ZIG, is it going right to the cancer site?
That's, that's the argument.
And, you know, how much of it is getting right to the cancer?
I don't know, you know, probably not a great amount.
So is it good to take ZIG orally?
Yes, it would be good to take ZIG orally, but we have to figure out another way to get it to the cancer site.
And besides injecting it, using a DMSO topically is the next best solution in my mind.
Does anybody else has any other ideas? Let me know.
So this is our new ZIG DMSO topical.
I just put it up on the website and made a dozen or so of these today.
So that's going to be available soon.